Why Does Red Meat Turn Brown When Cooked?
This is thanks to a protein called myoglobin,
which also is what makes the raw red meat
look red, not blood, as many people think.
Myoglobin is a protein that stores oxygen
in muscle cells, very similar to its cousin,
hemoglobin, which stores oxygen in red blood
cells.
This oxygen store is necessary for muscles
which need immediate oxygen for energy during
continual usage.
So how does the myoglobin end up making the
meat turn brown when cooked?
This darkening effect is due to the oxidation
state of the iron atoms in myoglobin.
When the myoglobin is exposed to oxygen, before
you cook the meat, the iron atom oxidation
level is +2 and it is bound to a dioxygen
molecule (O2), which makes the meat appear
bright red.
As you cook the meat, this iron atom loses
an electron and goes to a +3 oxidation level
with this process ending up turning the meat
brown.
White meat, on the other hand, doesn’t turn
dark brown like red meat because it has significantly
less myoglobin in it.
In fact, the myoglobin levels are actually
one of the main factors that officially distinguish
white meat from red meat.
Bonus Facts:
Contrary to popular belief, “searing”
meat does not in any way “seal the juices
in”.
Water in seared meat evaporates at either
the same rate or a higher rate, in some cases,
than non-seared meat.
What searing does do is play a role in browning,
which can affect the flavor.
But, in this case, the browning is caused
by caramelization of sugars combined with
a chemical reaction with amino acids and
the sugars.